welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross
vice president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact in 2009 doctors in Russia thought
that the 28 year old Ayrton sued Orton
and cancer he was a smoker and he came
to the doctors coughing up blood and
complaining of incredible chest pain an
x-ray revealed a mass in one of his
lungs and he was scheduled for surgery
to determine the severity of the issue
but as surgeon Vladimir Komarov began to
cut into the lung he discovered
something amazing in the lung tissue he
found green tree needles
he opened the area further and to his
surprise found a five centimeter spruce
tree inside organs lung I blink three
times and thought I was seeing things
the surgeon said then I called out to my
assistant come and see this we've got a
fir tree in here the five centimeter
sapling was removed and so Dorkin is now
back at work and feeling much better
his doctors theorized that he must have
inhaled a fir tree bud which grew into
the five centimeter tree and that the
tree needles were puncturing the blood
vessels in his lung causing him to cough
up blood
did you know friends that the Bible says
that Christians should also have
something living inside with him who all
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastors john ross hello friends
this is Bible answers live it's a live
international interactive Bible study
and pastor that bachelors away today but
our phone lines are open and we ready to
talk about the Bible if you have a Bible
related question this is a good time to
pick up your phone and give us a call it
is a toll-free number that number is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven say it again
you ready eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 God's
says if you only type it in based on the
letters of the words and a little later
I'll be giving you another number which
is our resource phone number so your mom
would also keep a pen handy write that
down and you'll be able to call for our
free offer for this evening I started
the program today by talking about an
amazing fact with reference to a 28 year
old by the name of 8 and Sid Orkin who
had pain in his lungs he went to the
doctors and they performed surgery on
him and if they found a five centimeter
tree sapling growing inside his lung
apparently a fir tree bud had been
inhaled by him and had lodged in his
lung and started to grow kind of
interesting that somebody would actually
have a tree growing in their lung but
the Bible says we need to have something
living within us as well and we're not
talking about a tree by any means but we
are talking about the Holy Spirit the
Bible speaks of us needing to have the
Holy Spirit in our hearts and in our
lives and if the Holy Spirit is living
within us then we have the fruit of the
Spirit manifest in the life of the
believer in Galatians chapter 5 verse 22
we read but the fruit of the Spirit is
love and joy peace long-suffering
kindness
goodness faithfulness gentleness and
self-control against such there is no
law well friend what do you think do you
want love in your heart and joy and
peace the way to obtain that is by
having the holy spirit abiding in you so
it's not only do you have love joy and
peace but the Bible says you have
patience and kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness self-control
these are the fruit that come along with
the spirit abiding in the heart and the
life of the believer how do we obtain
the spirit how do we have that spirit of
living within us jesus said we need to
ask for it Luke chapter 11 verse 23
jesus said if you've been evil not to
give good gifts to your children how
much more will your Father in Heaven
give the Holy Spirit to those who ask
well there it is God wants to give us
the Holy Spirit but it comes to those
who ask these in sincerity when we come
to the Lord in prayer we say please Lord
I need to have that joy and love and
peace and kindness and self-control and
gentleness in my life please give me the
spirit and as we submit ourselves to God
he's promised to hear and answer our
prayer we can have the spirit within us
we can have that joy and peace that only
comes from being connected with God
through the spirit well friends if you
want to learn more about how you can
have the spirit abiding in your heart in
life we have a book and that's our free
offer for this evening I'll be happy to
send this book to anybody who calls and
asks it's simply a phone call away the
book is called life in the spirit and
we'll send that to anybody who calls our
resource phone line and our number the
lumber for our resource phone number is
885 six seven four seven that number
again is 883 five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone number and
just ask for the book called life in the
spirit we're happy to send it to anybody
who calls and asks you can also read the
book for free I know we have some
listeners outside of North America you
can read the book for free by going to
the amazing facts website amazing facts
dot o-r-g and of course if you have a
Bible Christian this is a good time to
pick up your phone and
give us a call if you don't get through
the first time don't give up just stay
on the line we're working a new phone
system here this evening and so far it's
looking like it's working well the
number to call here to the studio is 804
six three seven two nine seven again
that number is eight hundred four six
372 97 and then just mentioned to the
call screener what your question is now
put you in the queue and you'll get to
ask your question on the air well before
we go to the phone lines we always like
to begin with the word of Prayer dear
Father in Heaven thank you that we can
spend a few moments together this
evening opening up your word and study
pray that the Holy Spirit would be with
us we recognize the Bible to be your
book and we need the Holy Spirit to
guide us to a clearer understanding what
the Bible teaches be with those who are
listening wherever they might be is they
traveling in their car or at home you
pray father that together we've come to
a clear understanding of Bible truth for
we asses in Jesus name Amen
well friends we ready to go to the phone
lines and now first caller this evening
looks like we have Carol calling from
Mississippi Carol welcome to the program
thank you annual question this evening
question is in the book of Matthew
chapter 6 verses 5 through 13 Jesus is
talking to the disciples telling them
how to pray and it says in the tenth
verse that your kingdom come your will
be done on earth as it is in heaven if
that be the fact and it's through his
will that you pray then why do we pray
for anything else or ask for anything
else from God if it's in fact the bottom
line it's going to be his will that's
done no matter what you pray for
well that's a good question when it
comes to prayer Jesus told us that we
need to pray thy will be done that's
part of what we call the Lord's Prayer
and yet the Bible also tells us that in
the Lord's Prayer in addition to just
praying thy will be done the Bible
continues all the pre continues and
Jesus says give us this day our daily
bread
lead us not into temptation but deliver
us from evil so there were some other
things that were also included in that
prayer then of course it finishes off
where thy will be done now when we come
to prayer we we are to bring to God in
prayer our requests our needs from the
Lord's Prayer that we just looked at
there in Matthew it's clear that God is
concerned about our physical needs give
us this day our daily bread so he
recognizes that we have physical needs
and we have bills that we have to pay
and we can bring our requests to God if
it is for healing or health or if he
interceding on behalf of somebody else
all of that is appropriate in prayer but
after we state what we feel we might
need we always recognize God's love for
us and we submit to what his will is his
will is best but it is good for us to
bring our requests to God and present
them you know there are times sometimes
where we might come to the Lord in
prayer thinking that we know what we
might need but as we spend some time in
prayer bringing our requests before the
God before the Lord the Holy Spirit
might convict us that maybe this is not
the very best thing that God would have
for us so in the process of bringing our
request to God we get
to know what God's actual wool might be
in that particular area of our life so
prayer at its core is opening your heart
up to God as you would to a friend maybe
sharing with him everything that might
burden you even your joys and your
sorrows and your hopes and your dreams
is bringing it all to God and and
speaking to him as you would to a best
friend and they would include you know
bringing your request but always
acknowledge God's will and his love for
you and say Lord your will be done
does that help a little girl basically I
lost my husband mm-hmm
two months ago hmm and the first prayer
to ask for healing and any that wasn't
going to happen the second prayer was to
ask for just him not to have to struggle
and that didn't happen and my third
request was to ask that he not suffer
and he did on his last hour hmm
which we had to be my decision to make
and I thought the last simplest request
what could it be answered mm-hmm well
you know that's a good question
sometimes we do ask and it seems that
God does not here we live in a world
with sin and as a result of sin there is
suffering you think of those who are
experiencing this tragedy even this
evening while we talk out there in
Florida with a hurricane and we wonder
why why does God allow these things and
God does not always explain himself the
promise is that one day we will
understand we also know that God loves
us and at times we can't see his love
through the circumstance through the
trial through the difficulty but we
still need to hold on to the promise
that he loves us that he hears our
prayers that he knows what's best and
and we cling to him one day all of these
questions will be answered a godly
explained to us why but in the meantime
really the best thing for us to do is to
hold on to his promises don't give up
just keep trusting the Lord there are
many examples of in the Bible of people
who have gone through difficult times
and they cried to the Lord in prayer and
it seemed that God did not hear their
prayer and yet their faith was tried and
they held on to God and God sustained
him and brought them through whatever it
is that they faced so Carol I can just
imagine how painful it must be for you
to go through the loss of your husband
but I want to just encourage you now
more than ever claim the promise of
Jesus that he will never leave
you nor forsake you believe that he
loves you ask him to give you peace and
one day all of those questions will be
answered and you will see that he is a
God of love and he's able to do all
things if we hold on to him Carol can I
have a word of pray with you let's just
pray dear father in heaven we want to
lift up Carol in a special way as she's
gone through this very difficult
experience of losing her husband and
sometimes father we ask why why do you
allow these things why is there pain and
suffering and yet your word reveals that
you are a God of love and we don't
always understand why but you promise
one day we will but until then Lord we
just ask for courage peace we can hold
on to your word that you do hear our
prayer and you will answer so we pray
for Carol I just pray that you'd give us
strength and courage and draw close to a
lord give a piece for we ask this in
Jesus name Amen
well Carol thank you for calling and
just hold on to the Lord he will sustain
you thank you for your call friend if
you have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven we have
about three phone lines still open that
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven if you call and you
don't get through immediately just stay
on the line we'll get to you as soon as
we can a next caller this evening is
Mike and he's listening from Minnesota
Mike welcome to the program thank you my
question has to do with the Hebrew
calendar yes and I believe the Hebrew
calendar this year is somewhere like
5707 you know anyway it's approaching
the six thousand year mars yes and
supposedly it's it's counting back to
the day of creation and my question is
this to God day as a thousand years and
a thousand years that's a day so
these are six days to them and the
seventh day which is a couple hundred
years down the road would be the Sabbath
right yes and somewhere along the line I
had picked up the millennial is God's
Sabbath is that correct well it's a
great observation yes in the Bible in
2nd Peter we read that a thousand a
thousand years is as a day in the days
as a thousand years to God now that's
different than prophetic time when
you're studying prophetic time in the
Book of Daniel and revelation then one
day is equal to one literal year but we
do find that principle also in 2nd Peter
where it says a day with the laws of a
thousand years so there is a principle
that we see in the scripture work for
6:00 and then rest on the seventh so God
created the earth in six days and then
he rested on the seventh day God told
the children of Israel that they were to
work their fields for six years and then
their field was to rest the seventh year
so we find that principle it is
interesting to note that the earth is
about six thousand years or coming up on
six thousand years and I'll talk about
the age here in just a minute but
according to Revelation chapter 20 when
Jesus comes the second time that the
righteous are taken to heaven and there
in heaven for a thousand years we call
that the Millennium but it just means a
thousand years during their one thousand
year period the earth is at rest it is
broken down with the presence of the
Lord and the devil and his angels are
bound in what's called the bottomless
pit Revelation chapter 20 so there is
that thousand-year rest for the Saints
there in heaven the earth is desolate
and empty like the field on the seventh
year when the Israelite was to let their
field rest so it is interesting that we
find that principle repeated in
Scripture now how old is the earth is
the earth exactly six thousand years or
is it still a hundred two hundred years
away we don't know I don't know I don't
think it's a hundred years away and but
the way you reach the age of the earth
is by adding up the genealogies that you
find in the Bible you know
Adam had Seth and then it goes on and
Seth had a son and gives you the age
when their firstborn son was born and so
you can add up to kind of work out how
old the earth is but it doesn't tell
what month the son was born it just says
the year when the son was born so it
could be the first year or first month
of that year or it could have been the
last month of that year so there is that
there is that unknown factor which if
you add up of all the generations it
could be several years if not decades
that it could move but as best we can
tell the earth is about or coming close
to that 6,000 year mark starting with
creation following all the genealogies
that you have in the Bible nobody knows
for sure when that's 6,000 year mark who
will be reached if someone does say that
I know the day in the hour when Jesus is
coming well that's a concern because
jesus said no man knows the day or the
hour yeah but we can't see when it's
near the Hebrew calendar is not accurate
for sure no it's not I mean it's been
proven accurate number sure no they used
the same names and ages that we have of
course in the Bible in the Old Testament
as well and what's not known is the
month within the year when the son was
born so if you if you look at that there
is a difference so it's very difficult
to pinpoint an exact date and say well
the earth is 6,000 years old but the
principle I think is good that's a good
principle yeah it seems to be common
sense in sincerity is the day of rest
yeah it's a little of creation and
salvation well it just seems to make
sense that when 6,000 years is done with
that's the Millennials
sure enough yep to make sense
well you know Mike we have a we have a
study I think you'd like it's on the
1000 year period it's on the millennium
and it's called a thousand years of
peace and we'd be happy to send this to
you if you would just give us a call I'm
going to give you the reason
phone number here write that down and
just call that number and say I want the
study guy called a thousand years of
peace and we'll send that right out to
you and I think you'd find it very
interesting it's a lot of scripture
talks about this principle that we took
in about the 6,000 years and then the
1,000 year rest the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
line ask for the study guide a thousand
years of peace and we'll get that right
out to you by the way anyone can call
and ask for that it's not just you Mike
but anyone can call and ask for that if
you have a Bible question a phone line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven that's
eight hundred four sixty three seventy
to ninety seven if you don't get through
right away just hold on stay on the line
and we'll get to your call as soon as we
can going to our next caller we have
Gardner who is listening from New York
Gardner welcome to the program believe
in a pastor when you're witnessing to
someone regarding the Sabbath and they
bring up Romans 14 maybe five that one
man esteemeth a day and and we shouldn't
be judging people about what the day
that they keep or what they eat what
should be our responsible what is that
scripture saying and what is it not okay
good good Christ let me read it I have
it right here it's Romans chapter
fourteen probably you're thinking about
verse five and six it says one person
esteems one day above another another
Steam's every day alike let each be
fully convinced in his own mind he who
observes the day observes it to the Lord
and he who does not observe the day to
the Lord he does not observe it he who
eats eats to the Lord for he gives
thanks and he does not eat to the Lord
he does not eat therefore and gives
thanks gives God thanks so the principle
that Paul is talking about here in
Romans let me give you a little bit the
background they were Gentile believers
in the church at Rome who had received
the gospel and they as a result of
Paul's teaching they accepted Christ
that were part of the Christian
community and yet there was some within
the church who had a Jewish background
who were insisting that the Gentile
believers
follow the ceremonial laws given in the
Old Testament which included
circumcision it also included keeping
certain ceremonial feasts and observing
certain ceremonial Sabbath days we're
not talking about the seventh-day
Sabbath you're talking about the
ceremonial days
it also included not eating certain
things on certain days and the Jewish
Christians were trying to convince the
Gentile Christians that they needed to
abide by these ceremonial laws Paul is
making it quite clear and he says let
each person be convinced in their own
mind he actually has a lot to say if you
look in the book of Galatians and some
of the other New Testament books Paul
has a lot to say about those Jewish
Christians who are trying to force the
Gentile believers to keep the ceremonial
law so Paul is not talking about the
seventh-day Sabbath not talking about
the moral law he's not talking about the
health principles that we find in
Scripture you're reading the Old
Testament that God gives a clear list of
animals that are clean to eat and
animals that are not clean to eat and
the reason the animals are not clean to
eat is because those are the animals
that are unhealthy for a person and so
that's the principle behind that so what
we reading about the in Romans chapter
14 5 and 6 really was connected with
those ceremonial Sabbath days which
could fall on any day of the week it
could be on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
because it was connected to a particular
day of the calendar and not a particular
day of the week and so that's what is
being referred to their law I knew
exactly what the answer was because you
guys have done a great job in teaching
me the difference between the ceremonial
and God royal law very ceremonial I had
my answer
thank you got it all right thanks so
much for your coal garden and we
appreciate it
our next caller is Sharon listening from
Michigan Sharon welcome to by the
Lanza's life well thank you for taking
my call tonight I really appreciate
welcome principals um the question is
okay
Jesus told his disciples that he would
not eat or drink with them until he came
into his kingdom so then he
after he was resurrected he appeared to
the disciples and so does that mean he
ate and drank with them a few times does
that mean he came into his kingdom at
that point or did he come into his
kingdom when he went up to his father
okay good question father
yep good question you know when Jesus
started his public ministry you'll
remember when he went about preaching he
said repent this is also something that
John the Baptist said he said repent for
the kingdom of heaven is at hand and
that confused some of the people this of
course three and a half years before
Christ's crucifixion he said the kingdom
of heaven is at hand
some people thought that that meant that
Jesus had come to establish a kingdom on
the earth but what they misunderstood
wasn't really until after the
resurrection that the disciples even
understood this is that there's two
phases to Christ's Kingdom there is the
first phase that we call the kingdom of
grace so when Jesus came he said repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand
he was ushering in a kingdom of grace
and what that means is if we receive
Jesus as our personal Savior as our Lord
and our King we are a citizen of the
kingdom of grace
if Jesus rules in our heart and lives
then we're part of his kingdom but the
kingdom of grace eventually will give
way to the kingdom of glory and that
occurs when Jesus comes again the second
time is king of kings and Lord of lords
Revelation chapter 19 talks about Jesus
coming and he's wearing many crowns and
he has a white robe and he has written
on his thigh king of kings and Lord of
lords
Jesus is coming as a king that is the
kingdom of glory and it's that point
that the redeemed will be changed in a
moment in a twinkling when I they'll be
caught up to meet Jesus in the air so
when Jesus said I will not drink of a
cup until I drink it and new with you in
my father's Kingdom Jesus was referring
to the kingdom of glory that would begin
when Jesus comes the second time so even
though Jesus met with the disciples
after the resurrection there was still
the kingdom of grace he did eat with
them but he didn't drink of the fresh
grape juice at that point the last time
he drank grape juice with the disciples
was there at the Last Supper in the
upper room but when we get to heaven
right and it's part of the kingdom of
glory then yes Jesus
we'll sit down with us and we will drink
that fresh grape juice and that'll be a
sign that the kingdom of glory has begun
okay wonderful he's going to have the
full feast upon us right that's right
it's called the marriage supper of the
Lamb okay the kingdom of grace and then
the kingdom of glory me and my friend
was discussing that we're over the road
truck drivers and we just we go back and
forth with questions with one another so
hey why are you on the phone I'll just
tell you one other quick thing related
to Christ's ministry there's also three
phases of the Ministry of Jesus when
Jesus was on the earth he fulfilled the
phase of being our sacrifice now Jesus
is in heaven and he's fulfilling the
phase of being our priest our high
priest and when Jesus comes again he
comes as a king so he is our sacrifice
our priest and a king and each of those
three phases have different time periods
so when Jesus said on the cross it is
finished his sacrificial work was
finished when Jesus says in heaven it is
finished it's at the end of his priestly
phase and now he comes as king of kings
and Lord of lords so there's three
phases to Christ's ministry as well and
precise priests had had priest and King
thank you very much you have a wonderful
black night all right thank you so much
for calling sharing friends we're not
going to take another call just yet we
can hear the music play in the
background the program is not over by
any means we're about halfway through
and we're gonna take a quick break and
it'll give a chance for some of the
stations to identify themselves and then
we'll be back with about another 30
minutes of Bible answers live so get
ready if you have a Bible question to
call and be a part of the program
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Ginny's 804 63
72 97 if you have a Bible related
question I've got my computer in front
of me and we have our Bible Software
open so we can study the word together
that number one more time you ready
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven if you call and the line is
busy just hold on we'll get to you as
soon as we can 804 63 72 97 a next
caller this evening is George and George
is listening from Washington George
welcome to the program oh thank you John
how's it going yes guy well yeah I shown
I like it a lot and my question tonight
is what your thoughts are what would the
Bible say on the fate of Pontius Pilate
yes
Pontius Pilate of course we know he
didn't really want to crucify Jesus but
he actually came out to the Jews and
said to the leaders I find no fault with
this man but he succumbed to peer
pressure when Jesus said or rather when
Pilate said about Jesus behold
King the religious leaders the Jews said
we have no king but Caesar and in
essence what they were implying to
Pontius Pilate if you don't crucify
Jesus and you let him go we gonna report
you to the high authorities that you're
acknowledging a different King and I
think that was the last thing that kind
of turned Pontius Pilate smiled where he
finally gave in and Jesus was crucified
head Christ crucified yeah yeah he had
his opportunity but he hardened his
heart and unfortunately you know if one
commits the unpardonable sin that of
hardening one's heart against God it's
not a whole lot God can do
if the person is hardened their heart
against the Holy Spirit and I think
there was the case of Pontius Pilate
I see so he had his moment and you know
of course I mean I think everybody was
pay imeem just at that time you know the
gentleness and you know the appearance
of Jesus must have stricken yeah like
it's like so many other Bible characters
you know at that time yeah yeah
it must have just been overwhelming you
know if your heart knew it would I guess
he had the chance to say oh stop
everything no no no well you know he
couldn't he had the power the religious
leaders couldn't force him and had he
stood faithful right at the beginning
when he said I find no fault with him
and if Pilate would have just insisted
that Jesus was innocent he probably
could have turned the crowd some water
you probably would have never convinced
the religious leaders but maybe some of
the some of the crowd but no when he
gave them that little bit of leeway when
he allowed them to beat Jesus mm that
was that was the last straw and then of
course there was no turning back from
there so terrible thing yes so your
thoughts are you don't think he'll make
it to the know you know we have no
record in the Bible of him coming to
repentance okay well keep up your good
work and thank you for answering my
question all right thanks you Col George
friend if you have a Bible question our
phone lines are open and the number to
call is 804 six three seven
- nine seven again 800 four six three
seven two nine seven next holy is John
and John is listening from Texas John
welcome to the program yeah I got a
question for you it has to do with
Revelation chapter 20 verses 4 to 6 yes
and they talked it says specifically
this is the first resurrection correct
and ok so you know according to those
verses who participates in that first
resurrection all right well let me read
it for you for those who are you might
know the verse but they might be others
out there that's listening on the road
and I'm just gonna read those verses
Revelation chapter 20 verse 4 we turned
your phone down just a little bit John
because we had some wind noise will turn
you up here in just a minute
revelation 24 and 5 says and I saw
Thrones and they that sat upon them and
judgment was committed to them then I
saw the souls who will be headed for
they witness to Jesus and for the word
of God who had not worshiped the beast
or his image who had not received his
mark on therefore in their hand and they
lived and reigned with Christ for a
thousand years
that's the Millennium then it says but
the rest of the Dead did not live again
until the thousand years were finished
then it says this is the first
resurrection verse 6 is blessed and holy
is he that is part of the first
resurrection over such the second death
has no power so here we we read about
this first resurrection it's referencing
the righteous they are resurrected when
Jesus comes the second time those who
lay down their life all the redeemed
throughout all ages are resurrected with
the second coming of Christ second
Thessalonians talks about that they are
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
all the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of Christ's coming so there
is a first resurrection for the
righteous at the beginning of the
thousand years there is a second
resurrection that occurs at the end of
the thousand years and that's for the
wicked the wicked are resurrected at the
end of the thousand years for what the
Bible speaks of in Revelation 20 has
been the great white throne judgment and
at the conclusion of that the wicked
mount their attack
on the New Jerusalem that has come down
out of heaven and fire comes and devours
the wicked and that's called the second
death that's why in Revelation chapter
20 verse 6 it says blessed and holy is
he that he's part of the first
resurrection over such the second death
has no power so there's two
resurrections the first occurs at the
beginning of the thousand years for the
righteous the second is at the end of
the thousand years and it's for the
wicked and then at the conclusion of
that judgment when the wicked mount
their attack upon the New Jerusalem fire
devours them that is the second death
does that help job well yeah yeah you
know I just thank you for I mean I think
you're trying to be as honest as you can
because yeah that those people that are
a part of the very because it says the
dead in Christ rise first correct then
we who are alive will be caught up
correct so these people who were already
dead were those who who didn't take the
mark of the beast during the tribulation
so I think you did a good job talking
about you know exactly when the rapture
takes place and the first resurrection
you were very good and you didn't mince
any words I take my hat off to you
Pastor you did a good job well thank you
John we appreciate your call and yes
that's what the Bible says with
reference to the second coming of Christ
and by the way I think you might enjoy
that study guide called a thousand years
of peace talks about the first
resurrection talks about the second
gives you all the Bible references then
I'm gonna call if you'd like to receive
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
study guide called a thousand years of
peace in 808 three five six seven four
seven that is our resource phone line
and friends if you call that number and
you can ask for that study guide you
might as well also ask for the free
Bible correspondence course yes we'll
send you these great lessons dealing
with these important Bible themes for
free through the mail you can study them
out filling the little question sheet at
the back mail it back to us we'll grade
it
so you'll find out how you did on your
test and we'll send you out the next set
of lessons at the conclusion of our
Bible cause you actually get a
certificate
showing that you completed all 27
lessons and it's free we'll be happy to
share to the anybody who calls and asks
my next call ease fill listening from
New York fill you on the air could you
hear me okay I can yes great first of
all you guys are doing a great job I'm
astounded at the knowledge that you have
it's very impressive
my question sir is this when Moses is on
Mount Sinai speaking to the Almighty he
says can you give me a name if the
people are to believe me I have to give
them a name and the almighty simply says
I am that I am that being the case where
does the name Yahweh come from okay good
question you know in the Bible we find
God referring to himself using not so
much a name as we think of names but
rather God referring to himself by
characteristics so depending upon the
situation depending upon what truth
about God's character needs to be
emphasized that came along with the name
there's many examples God is referred to
as the Almighty God is referred to as
the deliverer God is referred to as the
I am that I am and Jehovah Jireh the
Lord is the one who saves and it goes on
and on there's many different names that
we find in the Bible referencing God
specifically the I am that I am the
children of Israel were in captivity at
this point for about 400 years and the
question was well God does God see does
God care is God still able to deliver is
he still near us and when Moses went
back to the children of Israel and gave
them the name I am that I am that was
illustrating the fact that God did hear
their cries God is a very present God to
deliver them from their enemies that was
a very special name it was a name that
conveyed God's plan to bring deliverance
it's also interesting that Jesus
referred to that name as the I am in the
New Testament Jesus said I am the way
the truth and the life I am the
and one time Jesus said I am and the
religious leaders wanted to stone Jesus
because they recognized that it referred
to himself by the same title that God
spoke of there at the burning bush to
Moses so yes there are many different
names that we read about God in the
Bible but often it's connected with a
particular character trait that God
wants to illustrate through that name
okay excellent that's right to
appreciate it again
you really know your stuff and I thank
you so very much sir
Thanks thanks for your call Phil we do
have a book called the names of God and
it actually goes through this and gives
a number of verses connected with
different names used in the Bible we'll
be able to send this to you Phil or
anybody else that calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
that is our resource phone line 808
three five six seven four seven if you
have a Bible question a phone line here
to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven an ex Kohli is barb
barb is listening from Washington bar
welcome to the program good evening yes
I have a question concerning angels yes
no it's wondering doesn't Bible mention
how many angels there were before a
third of them were cast down okay good
question
no the Bible does not give us a specific
number but it refers to the angels in
symbolic terms thousand times ten
thousand and thousands of thousands now
when the Bible speaks of the Angels that
way and by the way you can read this in
Revelation chapter 4 revelation 5 speaks
of the Angels is thousand times ten
thousand and tens of thousands it's not
really trying to give us a specific
number meaning we shouldn't try and add
up all these thousands it just means a
great number of angels so there are many
angels if we stop and think about it we
have what about seven billion people on
the planet and at least for those who
are faithful to God we believe there is
a guardian angel on the earth and we
also know that there are angels in
heaven so there are many angels but
having said that based upon Revelation
chapter 12 with reference to the dragon
Satan it
says that a third of the Angels here in
Revelation chapter 12 it refers to them
as stars fell so one-third of the angels
of heaven joined Satan's rebellion when
his name was to Lucifer and he rebelled
against God a third of the Angels joined
his rebellion the good news is God has
two thirds of the Angels that are still
faithful and loyal to him right okay it
doesn't matter the amount just we know
we have more there are many you know
there's me and accompany the comforting
truth is we've yeah the comforting truth
is we got a guardian angel if we put our
trust in him and the angel is with us
yes so I just wondered if I missed
something like like there was a certain
number or whatever the Bible doesn't
give us an exact number for the angels
alrighty thank you then that will save
me from trying to hunt that down alright
no problem thanks for your call barb
god bless bye-bye annex coli's Danny
listening from Citrus Heights California
Danny welcome to the program
hello ministry Brad doing well thanks um
I have a question I attended church and
they minister from the NIV I was raised
on old King James Version of the Bible I
my father was basically raised in the
fire anyone who knows what you know
probably you probably know what that
means
and so they I was taught that the
closest thing to the root of the Bible
is the King James King James Version I
mean because they said that the more you
translate the weaker the definition or
meaning of the word becomes I don't know
that I'm no scholar or pundit and I mean
I know my word but I don't and then I
don't know if I should stop attending my
church because when they open up their
NIV I opened up my my King James Version
or my electronic King James Version like
oh yes I mean yeah let me tell you a
little bit about Bible translations a
good question we want to make sure that
we got the right word in our hands if
we're studying the scriptures without a
doubt so let me begin by just clarifying
different terms first of all when it
comes to Bible translations you
translations and you have paraphrases
and we need to make sure we know the
difference a paraphrase would be
somebody taking an English Bible and
writing it in different words maybe more
contemporary language so it's in the
English Bible whether it's the King
James or Revised Standard Version the
NIV and they they read a verse and then
they'll write it in their own words
probably the most popular paraphrase
Bible that's out there is called the
Living Bible very popular a Bible now
when it comes to paraphrase is what I
suggest is always I mean there might be
great inspirational thoughts and
devotional ideas that come out but if
you're gonna do some serious Bible study
you want to go to a translation so
that's a paraphrase the other is a
translation a translation is translated
from the original languages so the Old
Testament is translated from Hebrew New
Testament is translated from Greek when
it comes to the different translations
that are popular today there's not much
discussion with reference to the Hebrew
Old Testament the reason being is you
have the Dead Sea Scrolls and that help
validate the Old Testament so there
might be just a few little variations in
the Old Testament but but not as much as
in the new it's the Greek there's been
more discussion when it comes to
original Greek manuscripts there are new
families of or two types of Greek
manuscripts I'm gonna just back up a
little bit the New Testament came about
when the Apostles would write the
letters they would write letters to
Prime the church the church would read
the letter and then a scribe in church
would copy the letter and then they
would send the original on to another
church and the church would read it and
I'd copy it and they'd send it to
somebody else they'd read it and they
copy it so you know after the first
century AD there were many copies of the
letters and they eventually will gather
together and became the new Testament at
least the Greek New Testament there were
many different manuscripts and there
were two families of manuscripts the one
referred to as the Byzantine text of
manuscripts the other one the
Alexandrian manuscripts and those
Alexandria turned turned out to be sort
of a Christian Center and the Byzantine
Empire the Byzantine area which today
would be Turkey and Greece that was
another area where there were text the
King James Version he's translated from
original Greek manuscripts called the
Texas Receptus a guy by the name of
Erasmus was the one who compiled these
various Greek manuscripts and put them
together and the King James was
translated from the Texas Receptus
there's a number of other good
translations that also came from the
Textus Receptus some of the newer
translations like the NIV primarily they
use the Alexandrian set of manuscripts
otherwise known as the in you text or
the nestle allen text uh basically these
these original manuscripts are very very
close but they are just some slight
variations what I like to encourage
people to do is if you're taking some
serious Bible study recognize the Bible
is originally written in Greek in Hebrew
and today it's so easy if you have a
computer you have access to the Internet
if you're studying a particular passage
or theme you can always go to the
original Greek or Hebrew words and look
at where that word is used throughout
the rest of the New Testament Old
Testament really come to a clear
understanding of what the original text
is saying so okay I I don't have a
problem with the NIV I personally like
to use the New King James or the King
James Version but mostly the New King
James but I do then refer to other
translations as well but again I just
want to encourage people if he's doing
serious Bible study go to the original
languages I will so old King James
Bertram nuke is the clothes is pretty
contrary as far as being able to
decipher you know I like I like the King
James or New King James and I'll tell
you why because that Bible is been
around for so long it's been examined by
so many different great Christian
scholars and you know if there are some
words that could be better translated
and they are in the King James it would
not only be translated a little bit
clearer we know roughly where those are
just because it's been around for so
long so I kind of gravitated to that
yeah who's got you know the you know the
the Jimmy Swaggart commentary of a Bible
you know from you know the Hebrew so
it's pretty good too but at any rate
thank you for clearing that up for me
yes absolutely you know we have a book
on the Bible
that will be happy to saying you yep and
it's explains about the various
translations and let me see what the
name of that book is it's a new one the
ultimate resource is what it's called
the ultimate resource school let me give
you the phone number to call and you can
just ask for it the number is 883 five
six seven four seven eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven as for
the book called the ultimate resources
all about the Bible you can read it for
free online if you like Danny just go to
amazing facts to RG typing the ultimate
resource and it's there thanks your call
we got time for a few more callers let's
see we have Seth listening from Michigan
Seth welcome to the program hi I'm
calling with a question from Genesis
chapter 30 verses 25 to 43 and the first
time specifically asking question about
is verse 37 because it says now Jacob
took for himself Rob's a rod of green
poplar and of the almond and chestnut
trees and peeled white strips in them
and exposed the white which was in the
rod and the rods which he peels he sat
before the Fox and the gutters and in
the water troughs where the Fox came to
drink so they she can see when they came
to drink so the Fox conceived before the
rods and the Fox brought forth speckled
and spotted I'm wondering why when he
put the Rogers father in front of them I
wonder what I'm wondering why they
conceived okay good question sure yes
remember the arrangement that he had
made with Laban his father-in-law said
okay let me just take the the sheep and
the goats that that you don't really
want and typically the ones that were
spotted and speckled they weren't
necessarily the most prized or the most
valuable and so yes he prayed about it
and in the prayer God revealed to him
something that he was to do which was to
take these rods and in shave off some of
the bark and reveal some of the white
spots of the the tree bark and place
that in front of the rewarding true
watering trough now the wood itself the
sticks itself didn't really have any
value in producing speckled or spotted
sheep it was really an act of faith on
behalf of Jacob when he asked God and
God said I'd do this as an act of faith
and God was the one that provided the
blessing so there's nothing
intrinsically valuable or
you know that separated those sheep or
goats from the others it was more an act
of faith on Jacobs part in doing what
God had said okay all right good
question
thank you all right you're welcome a
next caller let's see we have we have
low there it is low calling from Indiana
Lowell welcome to the program hi how are
you and thank you for taking my question
you're welcome okay my question is when
we take our last breath here on earth
and desire so immediately go to be with
the Lord or does that lie dormant until
the first resurrection well that's a
good question I often people ask well if
if it's that the resurrection when Jesus
comes and the righteous of course all
resurrected at that point and taken to
heaven all what happens to the soul when
a person dies let me just talk a little
bit about the word solve in the Bible
the word soul often refers to the whole
person there is the spirit that refers
to the breath of life that a person has
when a person dies Jesus speaks of death
being like a sleep like an unconscious
sleep when a person closes the eyes and
death the very next conscious thought
that they have Jesus is coming and it's
the resurrection and they are caught up
to meet Jesus in the air they not aware
that a thousand years or 10 years or a
hundred years has passed to them it's
instantaneous
that's what Paul says to be absent from
the body is to be present with the Lord
the moment a person dies the next
conscious thought they have they present
with Jesus he's coming in the clouds of
glory and they are caught up to meet
Jesus in the air so there isn't some
holding place where Souls go where they
sort of just rounded up waiting for the
resurrection and then they are reunited
with their body what's the point of
having a resurrection if somehow people
are in heaven already it just doesn't
make biblical sense so in the Bible
death is likened into asleep and when a
person dies their next conscious thought
is their resurrected Jesus is coming and
they
to heaven all right well thank you very
much I appreciate your answer all right
thanks you a cold oh and I think we
might have time for one more caller
maybe yes we've got let's see
Evan easy-listening from Canada hip
Anisa we've got just about a minute left
what's your question
very good hey we got just a few minutes
before we run out of time okay my
question is on prayer yes if there is a
challenge in a believers life for wish
you go to God in prayer yes you faltered
you played music for higher anointing
and the problem persist what can you do
okay what point do you take it to be
maybe these God's will for me to live
with this problem or challenge okay good
question two things number one if we
have a need we ought to take it to the
Lord in prayer and depending upon what
the severity of the need is yes it's
very appropriate to spend time in
fasting and prayer for particularly need
so God doesn't always answer our prayers
the time that we wanting to answer it
God will answer it in the best time when
he knows it's best for us so even if God
does not answer that prayer immediately
we need to have confidence to know that
God has heard the prayer and we can
always ask God for peace through the
trial or the difficulty you probably
remember the story where Paul is
speaking about some ailment he calls it
a thorn in his flesh and he prayed
repeatedly and the Lord said I'm not
going to take this away from you but my
grace is sufficient for you and Paul was
sustained through that trial same for us
there are times that we face trials and
God does not always answer or remove the
trial from our life but he has promised
to give us grace or strength that will
sustain us through that trial so we can
always ask for peace the Bible speaks of
a peace that passes all understanding so
even in the midst of a trial we can have
that peace in our hearts we might not
even be able to explain exactly what
that is but we know God is with us
and we have that peace that sustains us
in
those trials so bring your requests
before the Lord trust in him that he's
heard your prayer and then allow him to
answer your prayer in his time but in
the meantime ask for grace ask for peace
and he will sustain you well friends you
can hear the music playing there in the
background we have run out of time for
today if we didn't get to your question
don't give up give us a call next week
and we will talk more about the Bible
again you've been listening to Bible
answers live for more visit amazing fact
so our G until next week god bless thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing fact
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 pack so RG did you enjoy
this program make sure to tell your
family and friends tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]